le président français quand on lui a
demandé de commentaire ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui a dit je le cite cela
représente un changement profond de la
nature de cette guerre je sais que vous
avez parlé avec vos homologues
occidentaux est-ce que ça signifie que
l'Occident pourrait fournir les
armements qu'elle exige ou peut-être
prendre des initiatives diplomatiques on
envisagé pas jusqu'à présent
je crois que la seule différence entre
avant et maintenant
c'est qu'on peut se rendre compte d'une
chose lorsque la Russie perd sur champ
bataille dans le choc entre les armées
elle décide de terroriser les civils et
de créer d'édition qui sont
inconcevables du point de vue des droits
de l'homme
la plupart des missiles étaient dirigés
contre les infrastructures énergétiques
aujourd'hui et il s'agissait de priver
les Ukrainiens de l'électricité de la
chaleur pendant l'hiver donc c'était
dirigé contre la population civile de
l'Ukraine pour contrer les réussites de
notre armée sur le champ bataille c'est
ça l'évolution et nous pensons que pour
réagir à cette évolution il s'agit de
renforcer notre armée
et de la fournir de lui fournir de
nouveaux armements et de protéger les
civils contre ces missile grâce à des
systèmes de défense aérienne je ne sais
pas ce que ce qui peut se produire
d'autres pour que l'on prenne des
décisions
arrivant à ça
que nous sommes désormais un peu plus
proche de ça
je crois je m'attends à ce que les
gouvernements réagissent de manière
appropriée
à cette agression barbare
terroriste de l'armée russe qui était
dirigée exclusivement contre des
infrastructures civiles
j'ai parlé avec un certain nombre de
dirigeants étrangers le président a
parlé avec le président Macron et
d'autres et c'était l'unique sujet de
nos conversations est-ce que la
l'Ukraine est désormais autorisée à
frapper à l'intérieur de la Russie après
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
il l'Ukraine se bat sur son propre
territoire et a le droit de se défendre
et nous avons le droit de défendre notre
pays et de
réconcer ce qui nous a été pris nous
allons continuer de battre jusqu'à ce
que nous gagnions le président de la
Biélorussie a dit que la Russie et son
pays allait déployer une force conjointe
d'intervention est-ce que ça pourrait
être une attaque d'envergure sur
l'Ukraine depuis le territoire
biélorusse c'est très inquiétant non
seulement pour l'Ukraine mais aussi pour
les pays de l'Union européenne la
Lettonie la Lituanie et la Pologne qui
ont une frontière avec la bière Russie
on ne sait pas ce que peut faire cette
force conjointe d'intervention sur ces
territoires comment ils vont se
comporter donc c'est vraiment une
dégradation très grave de la sécurité
non seulement pour l'Ukraine mais
également pour l'Union européenne
l'Ukraine aurait dû faire preuve de
prudence ne pas humilier Vladimir
Poutine en bombardant le pont de Kirch
entre la Russie et la Crimée surtout le
jour de son anniversaire
je crois que ces gens-là devraient
parler
aux victimes de viol et leur dire que la
jupe était trop courte et que c'était en
plus le l'anniversaire du violeur et
c'est à cause de ça qu'il l'avait
il y a différentes réunions aux Nations
Unies le Conseil de sécurité
un vote de l'assemblée générale sur la
résolution qui condamnerait l'annexion
de quatre zones à l'intérieur de
l'Ukraine par la Russie quand il y a eu
un vote de l'assemblée générale au début
de la guerre de nombreux pays en
particulier du Sud se sont abstenus vous
étiez en Afrique après les événements
aujourd'hui est-ce que ce qui se produit
d'après vous depuis ces derniers mois
est-ce que vous espérez faire des
progrès et faire en sorte que ces pays
qui étaient neutres salit désormais avec
le crème
l'objectif de mon tour d'Afrique j'étais
le premier ministre des Affaires
étrangers ukrainiennes depuis pendant 30
années depuis l'indépendance qui est
fait ce tour d'Afrique était beaucoup
plus large il s'agissait de parler de
nos dans notre renaissance la relation
de nos relations avec l'Afrique sur des
questions d'intérêt commun les échanges
la sécurité l'enseignement
nous avons également évoqué le soutien
de l'Afrique et des pays du Sud aux
Nations Unies lors de l'assemblée
générale donc nous allons voir
s'il y a eu une évolution dans la
position d'un certain nombre de pays pas
tous mais un certain nombre de pays
merci infiniment d'avoir pris du temps
avant de rentrer en Ukraine de nous
avoir parlé ici à France 24 depuis
Nairobi Ken